point
public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ici
l'europe où nous allons recevoir notre
grand invité nous sommes en duplex de
bruxelles car dans une semaine aura lieu
entre les 27
le sommet de toutes les sanctions
possibles contre la turquie la
biélorussie et la russie sans oublier
des rapports tendus avec la
grande-bretagne ou la chine nous
défrichons tout de suite le terrain avec
celui qui est chargé de coordonner les
vingt-sept ce n'est autre que le
président du conseil européen le belge
charles michel bonjour monsieur michel
bonjour vous avez été nommé un président
du conseil européen au moment du
renouvellement de toute l'équipe en
poste à bruxelles l'an dernier
auparavant vous avez été premier
ministre de votre pays la belgique que
vous avez dirigé pendant cinq ans un
premier ministre rompu aux négociations
ardues puisque vous diriger une
coalition réunissant les libéraux votre
famille politique et celle des
nationalistes flamands
vous faites partie de la génération
montante des jeunes dirigeants europhile
alors sur le front du court aux navires
us 1 pour commencer le niveau de
transmission est alarmant en europe
selon l' oms où les états sont
versatiles dans leur gestion de la crise
c'est un peu la pagaille aux frontières
les tests qu vider les période de
quarantaine qui varie selon chacun des
pays on ne peut pas toujours prévoir et
s'organiser pour bouger en europe
peut-on d'ailleurs et espérer y mettre
bon ordre
vous savez on a été confronté à quelques
mois à confinement pratiquement
généralisée c'était une décision qui
était pratiquement impensable quelques
mois encore avant que cette décision ne
soit prise
on a travaillé très rapidement avec la
commission européenne pour garantir la
libre circulation des marchandises
veiller à protéger les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
on voit bien depuis le courant de l'été
spécialement depuis la fin de l'été
qu'il y a des préoccupations liées à la
recrudescence du virus dans certains
endroits en europe et donc des pays
européens agissent sur le plan national
et c'est non pour laquelle avec la
présidence allemande de l'union
européenne avec nos équipes
diplomatiques avec la commission
européenne aussi on tente d'encourager
les pays européens accordés
avantage les actions je vois ça n'est
pas sain parce que c'est la
responsabilité d'abord des états mans
méléro de l'union européenne c'est de se
retrousser les manches pour tenter de
s'engager pour améliorer la coordination
et pour améliorer les coopérations et ça
montre bien que nous avons raison depuis
le début d'être mobilisés afin de faire
progresser un vaccin et des thérapies
parce qu'on voit bien que dans les
prochains mois ça va rester compliquée
ça veut dire que décrocher un ou
plusieurs vaccins et veiller à ce que va
ce vaccin soit accessible partout dans
le monde et partout en europe
ça va être quelque chose d'essentiel
alors cette semaine l'europe a vécu
encore au rythme de londres et des
déclarations fracassantes de boris
johnson qui continue à souffler le froid
et le chaud sur l'union européenne alors
il vient de faire voter une loi interne
contredisant le divorce l'accord de
divorce qui avait été trouvé il ya
quelques mois
et aux dernières nouvelles eh bien il
dit qu'il a bon espoir de parvenir à un
accord commercial avec les 27
alors est ce que c'est encore un nouveau
coup de bluff de boris johnson vous
comprenez ce qu'il veut exactement et
quel est votre avis sur l'issue nous
savons en tout cas ce que nous voulons
nous comme europe heures et nous le
voulons dans l'unité depuis le début du
british nous avez vu que malgré les
pessimisme de quelques observateurs
européens
nous avons tenu bon en restant
extrêmement solide et uni grâce
notamment au travail important qui est
menée par par michel barnier
nous voulons effectivement que lorsque
la lande bretagne décide de quitter
l'union européenne ce qui est son choix
et c'est là sa liberté
il y avait des conséquences il est
certain que le temps quand on quitte le
club de l'union européenne
on peut pas bénéficier de tous les
avantages y sont liées à l'appartenance
au club c'est la question du level pline
fille c'est à dire garantir une
compétition qui soit loyale qui soit
équilibrée entre les entreprises
européennes d'un côté et britanniques
de l'autre ce qui est plus préoccupant
c'est la décision d'un grand pays
le royaume uni de ne pas respecter sa
signature en mettant en cause son
engagement au travers de cet accord de
retrait qui a pourtant été validé par
les autorités britanniques et je pense
que ça s'est plutôt préoccupant dans ce
jeu c'est la crédibilité internationale
si cette loi est maintenu en l'état est
ce qu'un accord est encore possible mais
la commission européenne a annoncé
qu'elle utiliserait si nécessaire les
différents recours juridiques pour faire
respecter l'état de droit international
c'est un premier point pour la j'avais
compris que nous ne voulons pas nous
laisser ni intimider ni impressionner
nous savons exactement ce que nous
voulons nous aurons l'occasion
probablement au mois d'octobre d'avoir
au niveau du conseil européen c'est
l'art in les chefs des têtes du
rendement
l'occasion d'analyser où nous en sommes
et j'espère que les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines il sera possible de
faire preuve de raison alors l'un des
grands dossiers du tout prochain sommet
donc du 24-25 septembre c'est la chine
lors d'un précédent au sommet virtuel à
l'union européenne a appelé pékin à des
concessions pour boucler un accord
facilitant les investissements européens
en chine
alors qu'est ce qui bloque est-ce que ça
n'est pas l'ouverture en trompe l'oeil
de ce marché chinois mais nous sommes
extrêmement fermes et extrêmement
réaliste le premier point nous l'avons
dit la chine est une puissance
économique
nous voulons une économie ouverte et
nous voulons nous engager
nous voulons nous engager c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle nous
avons eu ce sommet avec la chine qui
faisait suite à une autre réunion
quelques mois auparavant c'était à la
fin du mois de juin afin de faire
progresser des négociations mais nous ne
voulons pas nous engager dans la naïveté
ce qui peut-être a parfois été le cas
dans le passé sur le plan européen nous
voulons rééquilibrer la relation ça veut
donc dire que nous considérons par
exemple sur le terrain des
investissements si nous comme européen
nous ouvrons
notre marché intérieur ce qui est une
grande valeur pour l'économie chinoise
par exemple il faut qu'ils aient de la
réciprocité sino-européen amenons des
contraintes notamment liés à des
standards sociaux des standards
environnementaux pour élever les
conditions de vie en sommes il faut
aussi qu'il y un mouvement au départ de
la chine qui aillent dans le même sens
sinon il ya une compétition qui est qui
est injuste et il ya une concurrence qui
n'est pas loyale entre des entreprises
européennes d'un côté et des entreprises
chinoises de l'autre tant qu'il ya
effectivement en chine
un certain nombre de réalités de
difficultés aussi la question climatique
nous pensons doit nous mobiliser en
europe dont 6 nous mobiliser sur le plan
diplomatique donc le message est un
message très ferme
nous voulons continuer mon léger que la
chine continue à mener le dialogue et
les négociations avec la chine mais nous
voulons que l'europe sans être agressive
soit assertive et fasse respecter nos
intérêts mais aussi nos valeurs charles
michel vous n'avez pas évoqué
directement la question des droits de
l'homme pourtant voix qui sont de plus
en plus bafoués notamment aux xing
jeunes contre les ouïghours qui sont
persécutés
il ya aussi les relations difficiles
avec taiwan y ait ce qui se passe à hong
kong
alors est-ce que ça c'est pas un
problème est ce qu'on peut encore
continuer à rêver d'une relation
économique avec un tel pays mais il est
certain que les droits l'homme stades
sont un thème extrêmement important
parce que nos valeurs de démocratie
d'état de droit de respect des personnes
des minorités sont sont essentiels pour
nous et c'est d'or pour laquelle le
dialogue était très très direct très
franc sur le sujet d'un jeune fille
d'ailleurs exprimé très nettement est
très clairement en disant que nous
demandions que des missions
d'observation puisse puisse pouvoir
constater la situation des droits de
l'homme en demandant que ce dialogue
droits de l'homme puissent s'amplifier
puisse se poursuivre et d'ailleurs
pendant cette vidéoconférence qui a été
longue
pratiquement trois heures de réunion
beaucoup de temps a été consacré à cette
question des droits de l'homme ce qui
montre bien que ce thème fait l'objet du
débat fait l'objet du dialogue que nous
défendons nos préoccupations par rapport
à par rapport à cela et nous allons
continuer à le faire sur l'île de lesbos
en grèce un instant
10 a entièrement détruit un camp de
15000 me grande
il a aussi poussé la commission à
accélérer la présentation de son nouveau
pacte migratoires avant donc ce sommet
du 24 25
alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez
vraiment que les vingt-sept sont plus
disposés à l'adopter jusqu'à maintenant
ils sont restés totalement divisé sur la
question
c'est le jeune fille rendue moi même il
ya deux jours à aller ce buzz pour leurs
rejetons sur le terrain de l'as de la
réalité aussi pour avc un message comme
leader européen
l'europe ne peut pas et ne va pas
baisser les yeux face à cette session
delà de la migration et c'est un sujet
difficile oui c'est un sujet difficile
dans les dernières années on a vu des
débats vifs sur le plan politique
partout dans le monde et en europe aussi
sur ce sujet là la commission européenne
avait annoncé et elle va maintenant le
déposer publiquement de nouvelles
propositions pour un nouveau pacte
migratoires et je pense ma devrait
effectivement se retrousser les manches
pour pour progresser alors je pense
qu'on peut pas voir lever le verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide ces
dernières années des progrès ont été
faits en termes de contrôles aux
frontières certains acteurs et des pays
tiers mais c'est insuffisant et je crois
qu'il faut agir sur plusieurs axes mieux
contrôler les frontières
effectivement les frontières des
graisses sont aussi des frontières de
l'europe
en plus de soutiens plus fait d'arrêter
et moi je soutiens par exemple à mort ya
cette idée qui a été lancé notamment
avec les pros ministre grec
l'idée que l'union européenne comme
union européenne soit engagée à côté d
autorité directe pour en première ligne
donner plus de solidarité à la grèce
et je crois qu'il va être aussi très
important d'être encore plus engagés
pour faire plus d'accords avec des pays
tiers en dehors de l'union européenne et
le message doit être un message en
faveur d'une politique qui soit ferme et
humaine ça veut dire faire respecter des
principes qui sont conformes à l'état de
droit
mais veillez aussi à ce que l'on ait
personne ne rencontre pas les conditions
pour être considéré comme réfugié
elles doivent pouvoir retourner dans
leur pays dans des conditions humaines
alors la tension monte en méditerranée
aussi depuis le déploiement de navires
de prospection d'hydrocarbures bur
turque dans ces eaux revendiquées par
athènes emmanuel macron est plutôt
partisan
de la méthode forte et a envoyé ses
frégates ils plaident pour de nouvelles
sanctions significatives contre la
turquie et beaucoup d'états s'y opposent
on va aboutir à quoi cette fois face à
ankara c'est certain c'est que l'on doit
avoir un message extrêmement ferme on
doit faire respecter l'ensemble des
états membres l'union européenne la
grèce chypre partielle des questions de
souveraineté qui sont posées par les
développements dans cette partie d'un
mythe et année ci est certain aussi
c'est que l'on doit avoir une stratégie
commune dans l'unité nous avons beaucoup
travaillé ces derniers jours pour
préparer ce conseil européen qui aura
lieu le 24 et le 25 et ce sera
l'occasion
j'en suis convaincue par ce que l'on va
continuer à travailler intensément avec
une seule voix européenne de dire un
message très clair et ce message nous
sommes prêts à être fermes pour faire
respecter les souverainetés pour faire
respecter les intérêts européens
nous sommes prêts aussi si des gestes
positifs sont posés à développer un
agenda plus positif on a tout intérêt à
sciez plus de stabilité plus de sécurité
et on a intérêt à être consciente de la
force ii représente ni européenne la
force sur le plan des valeurs la force
sur le plan économique sur le plan
commercial et sur le plan international
je crois que l'on a plus utiliser la
panoplie d'outils que nous avons dans
nos mains comme union européenne
c'est ce message là qui est un message
équilibré mais sans ambiguïté que je
pense de vendre et c'est alors la
panoplie ça veut dire pas forcément les
sanctions mais à certains pays qui
tiennent beaucoup à ces sanctions chypre
par exemple que vous avez visité
également chypre occupé au nord par les
turcs alors nicosie est tellement ferme
sur la question que s'il n'y a pas de
sanctions européennes contre la turquie
et bien elle refusera de donner son feu
vert à des sanctions contre la
biélorussie c'est l'autre dossier sur
lequel l'europe devra les 27 devront
plancher
la répression exercée par le président
lukashenko les baltes demande des
sanctions contre les dirigeants
notamment contre le président
loukachenko
l'europe est prête à sanctionner le
président biélorusse mais c'est certain
en tout cas c'est que nous sommes prêts
à parler d'une seule voix que nous avons
fait immédiatement au mois d'août en
réunissant 2
exceptionnel le lançant des dirigeants
européens pour donner un message clair
un message clair c'est nous démarrons
des sanctions parce que nous ne
connaissons pas nous ne reconnaissons
pas le processus électoral au loin
durant ce processus électoral de notre
de notre point de vue n'a pas respecté
les principes les principes élémentaires
nous avons cité très très impliqués
notamment pour tenter de mobiliser nos
essais qui est une organisation à
laquelle appartient de nombreux pays
européens mais aussi la russie et le
bélarus pour favoriser le dialogue
inclusif et en ce que nous cherchons
nous au bélarus et que le peuple
bélarusse puisse décider quel avenir il
veut grâce à des élections transparentes
et justes et équitables c'est ça le
message que nous voulons lancer ce que
nous voulons aussi c'est que les
principes de liberté liberté de la
presse et de l'opposition à manifester
politiquement de manière pacifique
puisse être respectés c'est ça
l'engagement que je veux prendre comme
président du conseil européen on aura
l'occasion très certainement semaine
prochaine d'aborder aussi c'est vrai ce
sujet là et nous serons très très engagé
je crois de manière générale c'est vrai
pour la turquie c'est vrai pour le
bélarus savez pour la relation avec la
russie qui ont été très importants comme
nous le faisons de plus en plus que nous
travaillons pour construire l'unité
européenne en matière internationale
parce que quand on est unis on a plus
d'impact on a plus de poids et sa vision
des sanctions bien question la question
est posée
on doit ensemble autour de la table
d'abord s'accorder sur la manière d'agir
sur la pertinence multi vite et à quel
moment et avec quelle ampleur d'utiliser
cet instrument là lorsque l'on pense que
l'on doit l'utiliser mais parce que pour
l'instant la la la contestation et la
répression surtout ont plutôt tendance à
s'accroître
c'est le cas aussi on pourrait parler de
cet empoisonnement avérée de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni le parlement
européen qui demande effectivement à
l'union européenne de renforcer les
sanctions existantes contre la russie
décidé après l'annexion de la crimée et
l'empoisonnement de skripal est ce qu'on
est capable et ce qu'on est capable
monsieur le président du conseil d'un
bras de fer avec moscou
je pense qu'il n'est pas n'est pas
question pour l'union européenne de se
mettre dans une relation d'hostilité
généralisée au reste du monde ce n'est
pas ça la vie
open mais il est question à l'avenue
crois que c'est très important pour
l'union européenne de se faire davantage
respecté faire respecter nos valeurs les
valeurs de démocratie l'état de droit
mais faire respecter aussi davantage nos
intérêts et de plus utiliser les forces
et les instruments dont nous disposons
et je pense qu'il était important sur le
plan de l'action extérieure l'union
européenne pourra plus d'impact de
travailler plus aussi pour coordonner
nos positions pour construire de l'unité
entre nous et mon expérience c'est la
suivante 16 sur beaucoup de sujets
lorsque l'on se coordonnent lorsque l'on
est plus dynamique pour veiller à ce que
l'on n'ait chacun les pays européens la
même analyse et se mettre d'accord sur
des actions en commun très souvent très
souvent on peut construire l'unanimité
plus rapidement que les impressions qui
n'est parfois donné il est vrai sur
certains sujets il ya des différences
plus importante entre nous qui nécessite
plus de travail et plus d'efforts
c'est un travail à la saq que nous
menons il croit que ce soit pour la
russie que ce soit pour la turquie comme
union européenne
nous avons effectivement la volonté
d'avoir un dialogue de qualité pour
garantir des relations plus prévisible
plus tard pour garantir la sécurité pour
les antilles et la prospérité
mais nous ne voulons pas être naïfs nous
voulons effectivement utilisé les moyens
dont on dispose pour défendre nos
intérêts charles michel merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en duplex de
bruxelles merci de nous avoir suivis je
pars tout de suite en direction de
bruxelles
rejoindre marie brémaud de public sénat
afin de débriefer le discours sur l'état
de l'union d'ursula von der leyen devant
le parlement européen en compagnie
d'euros député de premier plan
on se retrouve tout de suite pour la
partie des bas
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau
rendez vous entre france 24 et public
sénat
notre grand débat hebdomadaire depuis le
coeur de bruxelles au parlement européen
et bien entendu d'entrée de jeu nous
revenons sur le grand discours sur
l'état de l'union d'ursula von der leyen
prononcé le 16 septembre devant les
eurodéputés
une rentrée politique particulièrement
périlleuse pour la présidente de la
commission européenne qui est aux
manoeuvres depuis moins d'un an et qui
voit les crises s'enchaîner bien sûr
avec crise sanitaire du coronavirus
crise économique dans la foulée d'un
grand plan de relance qu'elle a annoncé
pour sa commission et puis il ne faut
pas oublier les tensions diplomatiques
avec plusieurs pays qui défie
actuellement l'europe
de très nombreux sujets abordés par
ursula von der leyen mais at elle
convaincu 1 les eurodéputés bien pour en
débattre sur ce plateau
nathalie l'oiseau bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne française renew
présidente de la sous-commission
sécurité et défense et ancien ministre
des affaires européennes bienvenue à
vous bonjour ya leur face à vous fabio
massimo castaldo bonjour vous êtes le
vice-président du parlement rupert
député européen du mouvement 5 étoiles
qui est inscrit pour l'instant chez les
non inscrits vous n'avez pas trouvé de
groupes de rattachement vous venez
d'italie c'est important c'est le pays
qui a été le premier frappé
chronologiquement par l'épidémie alors
c'est vrai que c'est une femme
j'ai envie de dire l'at-elle bien
défendu son bilan à j'ai trouvé au
soulagement dans la jeune claire et
affirmée et c'est ce dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui d'une europe qui s'affirme
qui s'assume
qui dit les choses elle a dit sur la
première année et notamment sur le début
de la crise de la queue vide ce qui
avait manqué et c'était une robe de la
santé elle a dit aussi ce que nous
avions réussi à faire ensemble à une
vitesse sans précédent face à une crise
sans précédent sur le mécanisme de
chômage partiel les fonds d'urgence
débloquée très vite et puis maintenant
le plan de relance
et puis surtout halal marquer une ligne
claire sur un certain nombre de sujets
essentiels autour du cou
dil autour de l'étape droit et autour
des tensions géopolitiques donc fait un
bon discours alors justement un peu d'
annonce tout de même d'un discours
fleuve si ce n'est la transition
énergétique et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique je vous propose
de l'écouter
nous avons réalisé une consultation
publique très large et mener une étude
d'incidence très large également sur
cette base la commission européenne
propose de renforcer l'objectif 2030 de
réduction des émissions pour atteindre
au moins 55%
je reconnais que cette augmentation de
40 à 55 %
c'est peut-être trop pour certains et ce
n'est pas assez pour d'autres fabio
massimo castaldo elle prétend que c'est
un accord que c'est en accord avec les
objectifs de l'accord de paris les verts
eux disent faux et vous disons que on a
trouvé cette annonce assez cohérente
avec le niveau d'ambition que pour
laquelle on a voté justement la
confiance ça fait un nom à cette
nouvelle commission
bien sûr de notre côté on voudrait
toujours de renforcer ce niveau
d'ambition et assurer bien calé le ton
qu'il a proposé selon respecter on sait
qu'il faut avoir une négociation assez
délicate aussi avec les conseils on a du
pays qui sont assez réticents notamment
encore la pologne qui est très liée à sa
production industrielle se situe du
charbon mais le charbon appartient à un
autre siècle ce n'est pas les sacs dans
lesquels on est en train de vivre dans
lesquels on peut accepter encore une
position qui entama et vraie attaque
l'avenir de nos enfants l'avenir adele
est aussi de notre qualité de la vie et
donc sur ces là on a trouvé les discours
ambitieux mais je pose aussi en action
sur le fait qu' on aurait aimé et
écouter un peu plus les mots social dans
ce discours ans et c'est important
d'avoir réaffirmer les principes du
salaire minimum pour lesquels on avait
obtenu son accord à son consentement ça
fait un an mais je trouve qu'il est
pillée social devaient être plus
présente plus au coeur de l'agenda
politique européenne sociale et économe
est-ce qu'on n'est pas aussi encore dans
l'opposition économie versus écologie à
pâques de relance grand plan de relance
pardon à 750 milliards d'euros qu'elle
veut financés par des obligations vertes
à 30% la finance vers le verdissement
c'est bien tout ça mais dans une crise
économique qui frappe très durement et
elle a redit nos entreprises nos pme est
ce que c'est une vraie priorité ou
simplement affiché c'est une vraie
priorité et ce qui est important dans ce
qui est en train de se construire
c'est que en effet 37% de nexio nos
relations ue va à la transition verte et
que dans chaque état membre dans chaque
état membre
il faut qu'ils aient ce même effort on
fait pas de la relance qui va contre les
objectifs des accords de paris qui va
contre l' objectif de neutralité carbone
en 2050 on se donne les moyens on se
finance on finance le plan de relance
avec au moins et dans vous dites en
grenier aux accords de paris l'a en tout
cas sous c'est votre sentiment
nous on a poussé et on a voté pour 60 %
de diminution en 2030 et non cinq ans
design comme lé nom 55 d'ailleurs ce
matin elle a dit au moins 55
il faut faire le maximum il faut surtout
s'assurer que chaque état membre fait sa
part et il ya aussi particulier à mon
avis essentiel ce qu'on a appelé le
fonds de transition juste qui est
destiné à accompagner les régions qui
vont devoir abandonner le charbon pour
faire très très simple elles ne pourront
toucher les crédits de ce fonds que si
elle se conforme aux objectifs de
diminution des gaz à effet de serre donc
on met tous dans la même direction et le
mécanisme carbone aux frontières
van der leyen a parlé à plusieurs
reprises notamment parce que ça peut
être une ressources propres pour l'union
européenne mais c'est aussi le moyen
d'exporter notre ambition
environnementale ou resteront la reine
auprès des autres alors sur l'aspect un
sanitaire la patronne de la commission
préconise de passer à l'union européenne
de la santé notamment par la création
agence de recherche biomédicale est ce
que les états vous êtes d'accord très
clairement ils doivent l'être parce que
ces pandémies a démontré clairement que
le virus ne reconnaît pas des frontières
ils ont mis en cause toute la façon dont
on l'a intégré nos états à l'intégration
des frontières l'intervention du marché
comment est donc aujourd'hui il faut
avoir les réponses parvenir à un
consensus et les zetas moi je pense je
pense que oui et le fait qu'il ait
annoncé aussi un sommet global sur la
santé and italy l'année prochaine en
coopération avec le premier ministre du
japon compte et je pense que c'est un
message est très simple pourtant
parce que on va coller ensemble l'action
l'union européenne est aussi la
présidence italienne du g20 pour
démontrer qu'ils une antenne peut ouvrir
une veine un nouveau parcours nouvelle
direction et je pense que avoir quelques
gaullisme des états qui aujourd'hui et
pourrait défendre une vision très
étroite de la réponse unitaire qui on
doit donner avec les moyens qu'ils n'ont
européenne qui peut mobiliser que
n'importe quel pays
tout ce ne peut pas bien sûr à mettre
sur la table ce serait une faute
historique donc je suis assez confiant
qu'on trouvera un bon qu'au premier un
bon accord ambitieux sur cette man alors
cette patronne de la commission n'a pas
éludé un gros dossiers de la rentrée
quand même à savoir une petite et une
entrée particulièrement chaotique
pour ce qui est de nos relations avec
les puissances extérieures en commençant
par la chine et on écoute ce qu'elle a à
dire est ce qu'elle a à proposer surtout
pour sortir de l'impasse de nos
relations avec des pays tiers qui ne
respecteraient pas les mêmes valeurs que
nous à droite on se bat mais qu'est ce
qui nous retient ouailles à yb
pourquoi est-ce que même de simples
déclarations sur les valeurs européennes
sont
retardée diluée ou prise en otage pour
d'autres raisons
lorsque des états membres disent que
l'europe et rolande je leur réponds fait
preuve de courage est passé à au vote à
la majorité qualifiée au moins sur les
questions de droits de l'homme et de
mise en oeuvre des sanctions
ça vous paraît l'urgence nathalie
loiseau finalement c est cette fameuse
majorité qualifiée qui nous
empêcheraient d'avoir des vétos des pays
qui voudrait pas qu'on sanctionne la
chine la turquie la russie surtout
effectivement et ça c'est urgent et un
certain nombre de pays à travers le
monde qui tirent profit d'une europe
quand elle est divisée ou quand elle est
lente à se décider et on le voit on a vu
que d'une certaine manière les routes de
la soie s'était pas toujours destiné à
aider des pays européens s'étaient
plutôt destiné à les morceaux les alors
nabeul à prendre effectivement que cc cc
c'est que ce sont des accords de
partenariat que 1 a d'ailleurs les
italiens ont signé un monsieur cassables
doigt les routes de la soie ça se voit
le seul le gouvernement a signé lisais
beaucoup qui le regrettent ces
désaccords commerciaux qui vise à
diviser l'europe vous dites se sont pas
vraiment des accords commerciaux sont
des accords qui sont destinés à endetter
des pays et ensuite à ce que la chine
puisse fixer ses conditions sont des
accords qui nous fragilise
pour répondre à votre question sur la
majorité qualifiée bien sûr que c'est
l'urgence on voit le temps qu'il nous
faut pour décider des sanctions à
destination de loukachenko en
biélorussie on voit le temps qu'il nous
faut pour décider de sanctions sur la
turquie quand elle viole la souveraineté
européenne
en méditerranée les opérations la chine
ce qui nous empêche surtout déclencher
des sanctions contre la violation des
droits de l'homme a hong kong ou à
l'encontre des ouïghours
est-ce que c'est pas simplement les
investissements alléchant avec une chine
incontournable mais si je peux me
permettre d observer disons les niveaux
d'échangés bilatéraux à des différents
pays hors pair avec la chine s'est
passionnément l'italie qui fait la
partie du lion dans ce débat c'est
plutôt l'allemagne qui a presque 100
milliards d'euros des changes
chaque année et ensuite la france elle
en a beaucoup plus que nous nous on a
justement on a et ça donne apparemment
vous le déplorez quand même comment vous
le déplorez est semble-t-il
on essaye bien sûr de les gagner une des
possibilités d'export pour notre bien
c'est normal il ya qu à 20 250 millions
de personnes des classes moyennes en
chine qui célèbre bien heureux d'acheter
du bond de la bonne nourriture mais
limitent à l'idée que c'est normal
chacun est décèdé valoriser et ses excès
lancée mais de l'autre côté bien sûr il
faut être très attentif sur les plans
sécuritaire sur les plans politique je
veux souligner que les depuis qu'ils ont
la législature le plus avancé en europe
la question des 5 g et donc la question
sur la vie intellectuelle c'est l'italie
et la france
on a qui ont adopté de l'alléger de la
plus dure assez bien d'autres pays qui
pourraient être un peu le trou de la
sécurité européenne dans un marché
unique intégrée en quoi on arrête notre
partenariat sur les investissements par
exemple qu'on avait c'est pas une bonne
idée c'est ça qu'elle a dit où c'est pas
vraiment ça qu'il a dit c'est que ce
qu'on demande à la chine c'est la
réciprocité et pour les intérêts et nos
valeurs vont dans le même sens
est ce que vous croyez que demain la
chine va renoncer au plus grand marché
solvable du monde et l'union européenne
mais même pas en rêve ce que nous avons
fait jusqu'à maintenant c'est péché par
naïveté péché par mollesse nous
attendions toujours que la chine se
transforme d'elle-même
et pendant ce temps là nous partions
séparer essayant d'avoir nos marchés
pour des entreprises nationales alors
est-ce qu'on me nathalie l'oiseau pêche
pas aussi par mollesse par rapport à la
turquie quand vous entendez une hanche
de la van der leyen afficher sa
solidarité avec nos états membres chypre
et la grèce et condamné les menaces d re
2 e et amer même temps parler uniquement
de désescalade ce qui est pas la
tonalité d'un emmanuel macron qui n'a
pas hésité à aller mouiller ses frégates
quand il sentait que ça se passait mal
an en méditerranée vous dit quoi que la
désescalade
on la souhaite mais que pour l'obtenir
il a fallu qu'il y ait des exercices
militaires
d'ailleurs auquel l'italie a participé
la france aussi est massivement
il a fallu installer un rapport de force
pour pouvoir commencer la négociation il
n'est pas possible car do and co
sider que la méditerranée et son terrain
de jeu qu'ils puissent ils violaient le
droit international
impunément alors installez un rapport de
force la présidente elle a clairement
haussé le ton contre le président
polonais etc au niveau cent lgbt sur la
violation des droits d'ailleurs elle
préconise la conditionnalité des aides
c'était une ligne rouge pour une
majorité au parlement s'était également
une ligne rouge pour vous absolument oui
on a toujours soutenu que c'était
inacceptable au sein de l'union
européenne qu'il souhaite être vraiment
le principal promoteur de la défense des
droits de l'homme de l'état de droit il
ya encore des états qui ont signé des
droits qui devrait être aujourd'hui
plutôt de droit que nous on défend avec
nos noms de nos partenaires et avec les
pays tiers mais même sans aujourd'hui en
europe on a cette incohérence et moi
j'ai souhaité j'espère d'avoir une
clause des conditions il est très forte
je suis un peu disons pas si optimiste
sur cela parce qu'on sait bien que ce
pays n'est ni probablement n'auront
aucun problème a soulevé aussi un veto
sur les bilans l'armée pour éviter qu'il
y ait finalement une conditionnalité
comme il le faut mais toujours le
problème la majorité et du droit de veto
ou exactement les problèmes de
l'unanimité qui est en train de vraiment
et faiblir à la cohérence et la force de
l'action non européens de sujets peux me
permettre une réflexion aussi sur la
turquie si vous me permettez
et moi je trouve que les comportements
d'un pays qui est d'un côté
officiellement encore candidat à
l'adhésion
même si personne ne croit plus à ces
parcours aujourd'hui avec ces
gouvernements que la présidence erdogan
est un pays qui est un des pays les plus
importants de l'otan ce n'est pas un
comportement que s'est adonné à côté de
la grèce et de chypre on espère des war
ar lancement ce qui est crédible des
négociations mais de l'autre côté si on
a pas d'unité s'il n'y a pas de volonté
très claire vient enfin de défendre nos
pays membres bien sûr le risque de voir
une érosion de plus en plus de notre
visibilité sur le plan international un
dernier mot d'un pays qui a joué un peu
les trouble fêtes qui n'est plus dans
l'union européenne depuis peu mais qui
apparemment se comporte comme un pays
tiers
effectivement qui nous bouscule un peu
elle a parlé du brésil
salué le trip 2 le travail de michel
barnier qui reste à la manoeuvre et
négociateur contrairement à certaines
facs news on peut on ne peut
unilatéralement modifier les traités dit
elle c'est un message envoyé aux
britanniques assez ferme aussi à
quelques mois d'un père exil exit c'est
un message très clair et très ferme et
en ce qui nous concerne puisque moi je
travaille sur le breakbeat au parlement
européen nous avons dit très clairement
que si jamais il y avait un accord sur
la relation future
on en est loin pour le moment nous
parlement européen nous refuserions de
le ratifier
tant que les britanniques ne respectent
pas la lettre et l'esprit du de l'accord
de retrait qu'ils ont négocié avec nous
qu'ils ont signé avec nous que nous
avons ratifié de part et d'autre on ne
peut pas violer ses engagements on ne
peut pas porter atteinte à un ordre
international basé sur des règles
boris johnson n'a plus beaucoup de temps
pour choisir s'il reste parmi ceux qui
croient dans le droit international ou
s'il passe du côté obscur de la force
c'est très clair et bien ce seront les
mots de la fin merci à nos invités
d'être venu sans ce blason et merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission et
vous restez sur nos antennes nous vous
donnons rendez vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]